okay one thing that was different for me
is how much
i thought i would go to akihabara versus
how much i actually go to akihabara
oh my gosh too yeah yeah because every
time we we haven't gone since you guys
moved
i know it makes me so sad like because i
remember
like when every time we visited here on
holiday we'd spend
half our time there or something like
that of course going to akihabara it's
the proper way
experience i'm not proud to admit that i
i it was like it was like the
like imagine every single anime
convention shoved into one it is like a
mecca of weed it is just the holy land
for yeah
but then you move here and you're like
man akihabara is not only a long way
away
but you can get a lot of [ __ ] better
online for cheaper
if you can figure out japanese not only
that but there are just like cities that
just are better for like all round like
experiences like that that's why i love
like ikebukuro yeah yeah
because with akihabara you only go there
for anime yeah if you don't if you want
to do something else then it's
not the best place to go but if you go
somewhere like ikebukuro you can still
shop for anime figurines you can still
go you know go
go down automate exactly exactly go go
to the animate there which is also in
akihabara yeah but then you could
also go to an izakiya afterwards or go
karaoke or you know
a lot of other things it's a lot more
varied there's a lot more variation
outside of akihabara than um
if you want just not to downplay
akihabara though no it's amazing don't
like it
no like you every weeb should go to
akihabara yeah
it's an experience you'll have a
spiritual awakening when you go down but
it is crazy like the first time you go
there yeah holy [ __ ]
what this is what i dreamed about three
sega arcades
right next to each other why it's just
kind of like information overload right
yeah you get blasted with
so many lights with so so much [ __ ] just
around you you don't know where to go
you can spend an entire [ __ ] day in
one store
oh yeah yeah easily because if you want
to look for deals right and figures you
got to pull out the whole shelf because
they they hide [ __ ] like
way in the back and sometimes you might
find that one deal that is like all you
[ __ ] talk about yeah
when i found that one thing for like 20
bucks yeah if you want to get a figurine
for like the best price
you got to like create like a google
spreadsheet all right this store has it
for this price but the store down there
has a 10 cheaper so you gotta like keep
track of everything yeah yeah
and then you ultimately realize that
it's it's cheaper than on uh
like it's it's way better to buy online
yeah even amazon here like the figures
are way cheaper sometimes in the stores
which is like weird